When we're looking at ways to approach animation in Unreal Engine, we've got a few different
animation types to go over here.
So when you're animating within Unreal, you've got the input animation, linear animation,
and Live Link.
And so I'll just discuss a little bit about what each of these are.
So input animation is typically where the user wishes to control or play the scene.
Any inputs that they're pressing on a wide range of input controllers, whether it's
a touchscreen, iPad, gamepad controller, the animation system drives the animation
through pushing a capsule that talks to that animation system.
So then the output of that is typically a character, in our example a pawn, which can
be a bipedal, quad, a vehicle, whatever kind of pawn you would like there.
The controller possesses that pawn and runs it around in the world.
So that's what we mean when we say input animation.
Linear animation is bringing in animation files into Unreal coming from some kind of
FBX exporter, which we'll talk about the FBX exporter in the next few slides.
But linear animation will be something that's come from your DCC app maybe, or some kind
of live mocap data.
So you can also bring that in via Alembic, which is the raw data, frame by frame cache,
and apply it to the sequencer using a control rig or even keyframed directly inside the
sequencer.
The last animation type will be Live Link, and this is a plugin that allows you to connect
a mocap suit, you can connect it to Maya or maybe some other 3D application, and you can
drive animations live inside of Unreal Engine.
So by having one-to-one information from your, through your Live Link plugin, maybe it's
using a mocap suit and you can see the performance happening live inside of Unreal Engine.
You can then use a take recorder to record all this input and export it to its own animation,
which you can then use in sequencer or you can play over the top layer in animation.
You can do a whole bunch of things with this information once you've got it inside the
engine.
But the main tool being here that you can see one-to-one feedback from the input, whether
it be a mocap suit or Maya or any kind of 3D application like this directly inside of
Unreal Engine.
So the type of animation sequences you can get, you can either have in-place or game-driven
motion and these are great for the input animations that we were referring to before.
These animations are in place, they're just on the spot animations, and then the animation
blueprint will push them around with the capsule based on player input and that's all handled
through code.
So the root bone wouldn't move in this instance.
If you want a more animation driven approach, it goes some place or root motion is what
we refer to here, which is intended for a sequence to drive it.
So we would maybe add keyframes in sequencer or do some other kind of action inside of
sequencer to push the character around.
If you enable root motion option, it will force the capsule to move according to the
root motion of the animation and animations need to have root bones for that to work.
So if you're using a Mixamo, AnimSkeleton or it's in the wrong place, you just need
to make sure you have a root bone with that option for it to work with the enable root
motion option.